no paremos hijos para la guerra es la
consigna que reina en el barrio de
puerto resistencia en cali agrupaciones
de mujeres indígenas y afrodescendientes
y otros colectivos civiles piden detener
la represión ha sido una semana bastante
dura una semana de tristeza una semana
de dolor una semana de angustia que no
hemos dormido por nuestros jóvenes
caídos ya es muy duro estamos sin comida
no tenemos empleo es una apuesta
impresionante que a nosotros nos hacemos
pasado en esta semana puerto resistencia
se ha convertido en los últimos días en
una trinchera de las protestas contra el
gobierno muchos de sus jóvenes han
muerto y muchos otros han desaparecido
en cali según la defensoría del pueblo
hoy estamos aquí marchando porque pues
queremos que ya se acabe la violencia
con nuestros jóvenes mucho más por
nuestros jóvenes acá salimos a marchar
como madres como mujeres como hombres
que también defienden la dignidad no
queremos más desaparecidos no queremos
más violencia queremos simplemente un
pueblo digno
en bogotá a la capital otras madres
hacen eco y miles de mujeres rechazan el
uso excesivo de la fuerza para que
fueron creadas las fuerzas militares
para que la policía está realmente se
desvirtuó se tiene una idea de que el
pueblo somos los enemigos del mismo
pueblo quiénes son los policías quienes
son el ejército porque quienes van al
ejército son nuestros hijos por eso
decimos acá no paremos hijos para la
guerra no queremos que nuestros hijos se
enfrenten y otro sea lo que se beneficie
entre las presentes hay madres de los
llamados 'falsos positivos' jóvenes
desaparecidos y asesinados por
integrantes del ejército que los
hicieron pasar por guerrilleros muertes
por las que en muchos casos no se ha
hecho justicia
la cifra de muertos en las protestas en
el país aumenta con el paso de los días
y las autoridades ya cuentan más de 500
desapariciones de las cuales sólo 189
han sido ubicadas el llamado es a evitar
que la historia del país se repita